it's cause for celebration now  you can enjoy a real taste thrill  yes it's the all-american favorite  hamburgers prepared from selected choice  be a feast in itself  Charbroil to give you that cooked  outdoors tastes hot and ready to serve  you right now cooked just right goodness  you can see and taste yes come and get  better make tracks right now to the  refreshment stand there's one waiting  for you any age is the right age for a  hamburger you want more well it looks  like fun burger time and for that extra  taste treat top it with the goodness of  golden bellow cheese a cheeseburger put  together just the way you like a  man-sized meal everybody enjoys